[Music]  I don't know I mean it was okay but it  seems like every single superhero movie  these days just an excuse for the good  guys to fight each other oh I know it's  like they think up the lamest excuse for  him to be mad at each other just so they  can stage a big fight sing at the end I  mean I still liked it I'd give it three  stars I'd give it 3.5 well you mean  three and a half yeah the same thing  three point five three and a half it's  not the same thing no one uses decimal  points when they rate a movie it's just  stupid you know there were times and  this is one of them what I just want to  smash you right here right  [Music]  you just started a war I'm gonna enjoy  taking you down wait  wasn't it just daytime and sunny we're  gonna fight in the rain again  [Applause]  Andy do you leave  [Music]  [Applause]  tell the devil conan sent you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh you do  [Music]  [Applause]  you